for those of you who missed the show
last night how dare you i did a little
monologue on
a dirty word known as assimilation and
in that monologue i mentioned
congresswoman ilhan omar
here's a little taste
ilhan omar was a refugee she came to
america as a young girl fleeing the
civil war in somalia
following four years in a refugee camp
in kenya she was granted asylum to the
united states
congresswoman omar has chosen to return
american goodwill
with grievance not gratitude you've
heard her
she views her time in somalia as
blissful
while criticizing the united states as
racist oppressive and torturous
well you know who saw the clip
and tweeted this america lets people
like pete
make a living out of being racist pete
couldn't make it to congress because
minnesota voters
rejected him ufta ilhan
that one really stings after all it's
not like you call someone a racist
every day oh wait
that's kind of your thing isn't it
you're right i make a pro america
argument
for americans of all races and all
faiths including muslims
and i'm a racist got it and some people
did something too right
but i have to agree with congresswoman
omar about one thing
i did run for office in minnesota and i
lost
in fact i got crushed and i'm glad i did
you see 10 years ago look at that young
man i would have been a terrible
senator even though i'd been to the
battlefield twice
fighting those people who did something
on 911
i was still young i was politically out
of touch i loved the establishment
and was really good at regurgitating
scripted talking points like a
teleprompter
the swamp would have eaten me alive i
would have been very useful for them
but thankfully the freedom-loving
republican voters of minnesota saw
right through me and made sure that i
stayed the hell
out of washington and it turned out to
be a gift
i needed frankly more time to learn and
to live and to listen
don't we all i didn't understand what
was really being done to america
by leftists like ilhan omar and it took
losing to help make me realize it since
then i've learned to you know
think for myself buck the group think
and especially the establishment i
discovered
we the people and i've been in love with
her ever since
traveling america meeting the forgotten
men and women and what they really care
about
was the best education i could ever get
maybe if ilhan omar had taken the time
to do the same thing
she wouldn't be leading the
anti-american caucus with her fellow
so-called squad members in congress
and not for nothing omar is using my
monologue
to fundraise you're welcome
congresswoman
some people might have some questions
about where that money is going or
something
you know hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else